people of the internet retro Records who
are here just a dad who loves games and
the stories they tell and we are back
with more Hogwarts Legacy Lord retro
Mort is here once again ladies and
gentlemen to do his bidding we are
playing on hard mode evil Slytherin and
what do we do last time let's see we we
finally got the broom that was a big
thing was really happy about that we got
the broom we also learned confringo from
who on this playthrough is going to be
our right hand man
Sebastian sallow
so now you can see where we're at in the
story we need to meet Professor Weasley
in the seventh floor Corridor and I'm
pretty sure that this is going to be for
the room of requirement we have not done
that just yet because I think that's a
pretty like that one takes a little bit
to do so that's why I saved it for the
start of this episode we also have
Professor Sharp's assignment here
waiting for us that's where we're going
to learn to pulso but to do that one we
need to acquire and use a focus potion
also acquire Maxima any duras potions
and use them simultaneously
so not too hard to do we need to make
sure that we acquire those at some point
so I'm going to go ahead and set our
marker here for the rumor requirement
first
and we'll go from there
and by the way if you guys are new here
we do stream this live over on Twitch so
we're streaming this with a live
audience twitch.tv retro wrecking tour
all right so we've got that marked now
for our next Quest I think we're gonna
go ahead and tackle that let's go ahead
and get to the room of requirement and
see what all we need to do for that and
also there is one thing that I want to
see
that I believe this is the only time you
can do it is when you are first gaining
access to the room of requirement and if
you guys have already looked at a lot of
YouTube videos and secrets and stuff
like that you may already know about
this but apparently
you can see the vanishing cabinet
from
that we know from the Harry Potter
series
all right so let's go ahead
use our little marker right here yep I
was thinking it's this way
and we will get started on our journey
for the room of requirement
oh but hold on
see because of the way you level up in
this game
I feel like you almost have to
collect the field guide Pages again just
to help you level up because that's
honestly that's one of the best ways to
level up is collecting the field guide
pages
you guys remember uh anybody in the chat
if you're watching this live anybody
remember what
level you beat the game at
trying to remember like how early can
you actually beat the game
away from prying eyes
dude she's late
[Music]
you took it all the way to 40 Dustin
before you beat it Christy about 29
that's what I was thinking like 25 to 30
somewhere in there
I guess the big question is what level
is the final ball forgive me
beard we got it Weasley wasted no time
no time
well we sounded creepy right there
after you Professor he sounded the part
right there
what is this
real need of it ordinarily a student
might stumble upon this room entirely by
accident if ever I'd only planned to
suggest to you how to find it by walking
past that bit of War focusing on what
you need but you've managed to reveal
the room on your own while I'm here we
should take advantage of the moment now
where is Deke
you must sneaked fast and gone ahead
Deke Professor the house elf I was oh
yeah we don't officially know Deke yet I
guess thought he might help you use the
all right yeah so this is
I think this is the only time you can
ever see this room right here
is this specific moment
like this this part of the rumored
requirement which what do they call this
one like the room of
forgotten things or something like that
okay so let's look around and see if we
can find it
The Vanishing cabinet oh my goodness
look at that
you think that guy's supposed to be
anybody special
or just some random dude
all right you got the floating candles
there I actually think you have to walk
walk through a little bit first before
you see it
but I'm just gonna make sure we look at
everything that way even if I miss it
I'll have the footage that I can go back
and see if we can pinpoint it later
and I also see I want to know if it's
one of those things it's like explicit
like is it pretty clear what it is
or is it just people kind of
making assumptions
wait is that it right there
there's no chance I'm clumbering over
this mess
foreign
I like that actually
I suggest you practice the wand
movements first then you can clear the
chairs away oh PS5 a few seconds behind
well I don't always respond instantly
either
final boss is at level 30. thank you
Christy good info good info
also could be uh I think you can have
different latency settings on Twitch too
like both on my end and probably on
evidence
all right so I think we have yeah we've
left that one pretty empty right now
okay
cast evidence on the chairs accio
wrong spell
the animation is so cool let's move on
just don't use evanesco that much I mean
real pretty much remove requirement
right
oh wait what is this right here
did I find this on my first playthrough
wondered where that had got to but what
is this I can't believe it hey I waited
for you here for ages
hold on
go ahead finish Weasley yes professor
all right are you done I do remember
finding this now hey I waited for you
here for ages perhaps you were assigned
a few more inches of parchment than
you'd expected let me know if you want
to try to meet again sincerely T A and T
Albus
oh there's a chess piece right there
look at that
looks just like the one from the movie
all right so that's definitely not the
cabinet people are talking about because
there it looks we've seen a couple that
look just like that one
like there was another one right there
looks just like it
once we finish the game you wish that we
could change the season yes that would
be so cool I mean it would kind of be it
would like break the immersion at that
point but once you've beaten the game
it's it's like who cares right
let us put it in any season and just
Just Go With It
let us Just Go With It
I really would like to revisit some of
the seasons though
especially winter I think winter was my
favorite one all right she's gonna keep
kind of looking through her school bag
here
can't you keep it down some of us are
trying to rest
I really should have taken my time the
first time through this to explore a lot
more
oh wait isn't that like the Headmasters
Podium thing
why is it in here maybe it was a
previous version or something
same thing for the little
boar right there maybe that was a
previous uh
decoration here at Hogwarts they have
some scales right here
okay that looks like something
a little different from everything else
that we've seen so far
Rebellion
yeah if anybody knows where the
vanishing cabinet supposedly is
let me know and we'll try to find it
here
oh they said the little Jack in the Box
looks like Snape I did hear somebody say
that
let me go back let's see what you guys
think
oh no can we not
oh is he gone forever
oh come on
come back Snape
come back
oh well that's no fun he's gone now
okay there's an yeah I mean these just
look like normal cabinets over here to
me
at least so far
little teacup right there
all right so
let's see what this is
because we can vanish that over there
but before we do that
we've got to get an unidentified back
item
all right
and then of course you can slide down I
guess you can't go up that way though
all right I was about to say did we just
waste our time with that
hovering right there
it's in there somewhere probably I know
right like
I do remember people I do remember
watching videos where people went
through and said hey and there's the
vanishing cabinet that Draco Malfoy uses
in Harry Potter
and the Half Blood Prince
I mean right now we're still good we
could backtrack through all our faces if
we needed to
and actually there is a specific
there is a specific area in here where
on my first playthrough I ended up
giving up because I couldn't figure out
what they wanted us to do
oh no you
nope see it feels like we should be able
to repair oh him right there
[Music]
see again another cabinet but that one
just looks like the regular one
you made the dumb mistake of not knowing
you could sell your gear oh instead of
dismantling it I dismantle it a lot like
when I'm oh wait wait wait that might
I think that's it right there
yeah that one looks very different
I just want to picture oh yeah that's
totally it
that is totally it
this probably won't show up well if I
hold it up to the screen but
yeah if you guys just Google Vanishing
cabinet Half Blood Prince and then
search by images you'll see it there
don't go inside it I know I wonder I
guess I wonder if the other one's
already in Oregon Berks you can't even
get over there that's probably why
because they know we would all be
we'd all be trying to go through hold on
can I hop on my broom
darn it would have been perfect wouldn't
it
all right well that is pretty cool I
gotta say I gotta say
yeah right over there
all right so now let's go back here
let's see could we interact with that
just knock those over
all right another evanesco
oh there's somewhere you can yeah this
is a funny note right here bit offended
the room thought I needed a bath cheeky
thing
what's going on here
whoa okay this
is clearly a special Gryffindor
decoration right here
wait hold on that looks like one of the
uh that's one of the counters
for the house cup
maybe that's an older one again maybe
something they're no longer using
anymore
that's one area where the magical
the laws of the magical world always
started to kind of break down for me
whenever I would uh some of those old
school Harry Potter podcasts that I
would listen to Potter cast and
mugglecast
we were taught they would they would
discuss like like think about Vanishing
and Transfiguration right like
how does it work Conjuring
you know
and then you just have to a lot of it
you just have to explain away yeah it's
magic
like if you conjure a rabbit
is that like did you pull a rabbit from
somewhere else in the world or did you
just create a brand new living breathing
rabbit or is it just like a a magical
rabbit sort of like a Patronus like
it'll eventually fade away
it's like when I'm ve like I van like
why not just vanish all this stuff right
like all this old stuff why keep it
around at all
and so then when I vanish all these
chairs right now like where do they go
the words of Todd Howard it it just
works
yeah they're they're always there comes
a point with any magical world right you
just have to
you know suspend
disbelief just a little bit what was
that
was that a golden snitch
another chess piece you should summon
your wits and find out leave me alone
Rebellion oh yeah this is the spot this
is the spot right here guys okay
so I'm like what the heck is going on
here
's the chest back there
how
I'm not gonna look at chat for a second
because I want to see if I could do this
because that one's easy to move
that one's easy enough to move
and then let me see if I can
come on I want to get you like over
there up against that
all right now let's do a Leviosa
let's see if I can jump over this now
no okay
fine fair enough so they have this
little area you can go in here
then it's like okay wait what's the
point of this
I think the point of this has to be
to move over something
oh this is so fascinating
all right hold on
and yes guys I know it's just gonna be
another
another clothing item
so what's the point would there be any
point to
going that closer not really
and I don't think we can fit that
can we fit that back through here like
can we pull it through this way
and then go up and over
okay wait what if I do this what if I
what if I levioso you
and then I accio the one with the chest
closer
oh
oh no I just glitched everything my
whole camera's shaking
oh no that's not what you're supposed to
do
look at it that's the chest we need
right there
let me grab come on
come on let me look through there
let me look through there
no
so close
all right I'll look at chat in a minute
if I don't figure it out
if we didn't we may have broken it too
we may have completely broken the puzzle
it's not working at all anymore
all right
let me think let me think let me think
all right let me try the other thing let
me try to pull this back through
try to pull you through this way
oh yeah I mean we should definitely be
able to clear that why can I not can I
not stand up yet
okay there we go
all right
now let's kind of push you over right up
next to it
yeah
okay see like we should definitely be
able to clear that
even better
no
come on Avalanche that should totally
work
that should
wait wait wait we're definitely not
supposed to be up here I can already
tell by how it's controlling right here
we can glitch our way in
let's glitch our way in
no were
all right I'm about to look at chat
I'm about to have to look at chat you
guys
it's probably it's got to be so simple
I mean right there look at that we're so
close all right hold on but what if we
go over here
I wonder if you get it if you get it
lined up right there can you grab it
what's funny is like the reward doesn't
even matter I don't even care about the
reward I just want to be able to solve
it that's all
I want to say that we solved it
levio so you and levioso you
open
oh come on
that totally work man
let me push you a little bit closer
hold on and then we're gonna we're gonna
accio you wait wait wait wait wait it
said search let's
ladies and gentlemen thank you for being
here tonight that's gonna do it
I'm kidding I'm kidding
I don't know how self can find us in
here look at that
oh
excuse me
no way
you can accio these all the time why is
this one not
okay that was weird
37 we needed that 37 Gold let me tell
you
that was so strange
all right I think we're about to get to
the room now
or at least about to get to the uh the
cut scene there's our boy Deke
what is up Deke
yikes Castle huh Annette don't remember
how I did it
went right there dick will come to you
you can accio the bags you can Dylan
you missed my tip video Dylan we went
over this dink was looking some of
what's appeared in the room since Deke
was last here
maybe I shouldn't call it tips for
beginners
I actually can't remember which video we
talked about it in we definitely talked
about it echoing the bags we discovered
this room together
I mentioned you to Deke
we believe that you
dick would you be so kind of course
Professor Weasley
the room thank you my friend will always
be here thank you deepika's needs it's
unplottable so won't appear on any map
most happen upon it by accident if ever
deep seen students in need of an extra
file for potions stumble upon the room
filled with them you seem to have
accessed it in its form as there it is
room of hidden things things I was
thinking about needing a place away from
prying eyes
brilliant oh that explains it then
you sounded so dark again without
destruction well then the route can
provide you with precisely that
now it's time to focus on what you need
Just Close Your Eyes
imagine the room precisely as you need
it
the room will do the rest
what a great use for the room of
requirement by the way
you know video game designers loved a
concept like that you know that you can
basically turn into anything whatever
you need it to be to make it happen
thank you
you've given yourself quite a canvas to
work yes we have
I feel so small now though compared to
what you can eventually
unlock here
with an owl to identify unfamiliar items
of clothing like where'd that owl come
from always understand the effect s is
that a magical hour
did the room just physically create a
new owl
is it a living breathing owl so many
questions you ever unlocked the desk of
description use it to reveal the magical
properties of any unidentified gear that
you've collected
all right
the desk of description and we do have
some things to identify already
wait what I thought we had more than
that really just one
all right well it was definitely an
upgrade so let's go ahead and equip that
and that's a pretty pretty sizable
upgrade right there
yeah see that would be a nice Quality of
Life Update right there if they made it
to where you didn't have to
change that out each time I probably
comment that every time I have to do it
all right so
let's just put up some stuff over here
and we'll just make it the small size
two so we can
all right so one
two
three
and then let's just do the large ones
here
or
I need to at least change the picture I
forgot to change the picture on the last
one
and five okay all right that's five of
those and then what else did she want
five
lore items so I guess rugs would count
as one
large Botanical rug
yeah let's do it just another Botanical
rug here
and you can change the color
all right
okay so that's one thing on the floor
[Music]
no everybody's phones are dying
I think tables and chairs should count
too right
scientific let's do another botanical
just kind of sticking with Botanical on
this play through for whatever reason
all right so that's two
two come on
come on
oh it doesn't like that spot right there
right in front of each other what
what
right there we go okay
all right that's two
and then with the table is three Deek
hasn't seen this many plants here my
goodness Deke
and let's do a small Botanical table
and then we'll just put two more chairs
around it
[Music]
what oh no what happened Christy why are
you freaking out what'd I miss
take another Botanical chair
let's do green
shall we move
what happened Christy I'm so confused I
Wanna Know
all right Weasley we did it
like to next Professor Dr sherbet and
Cloud Roth they want to know too
alteration the altering spell will allow
you to customize any kungent item
and change the colors patterns and
styles of your furniture to suit your
taste let's get started showing watch
closely as I demonstrate how famous
confusion today spell
all right
this one is
oddly shaped
there we go all right that's altering
just aim your wand at any conjured item
and perform all right so now hold on we
have to equip that too
and I will do it right there any
conjured item all right alter
oh no I didn't mean to do that I meant
to do this right here
so we can change the color of you
there we go
foreign
just stick with the green theme
no I didn't mean to do that
all right now while we're in here we
should also
try and go ahead
and get those uh
things that Professor sharp needed us to
brew
I think one was a focus potion alter oh
wait we have to alter the style and then
alter the size all right to complete
that okay yeah acquiring use a focus and
then maximum any dearest potion so we
can always go buy them too but
if I have the stuff already to
which I don't think I do I don't think
on this playthrough I've bought okay so
we need flux weed or no we need Ash
Winder eggs how do I not have Ash Winder
eggs those are everywhere
and in the focus potion we need to
purchase that from Pippins
hey let's go ahead and brew a wig and
weld though
architecture yeah this part blew me away
I could not believe
that they let you customize so much in
this room because it's one thing to
customize
the stuff that we've already talked
about right but the fact that you can
change the actual structure of the room
all right she said the balcony
scientific Botanical eclectic Gothic I'm
gonna go with we're just sticking with
the Botanical theme right now
and then you can hold apply to all walls
and bookshelves
yep let's do it apply to everything
Malfoy's in the pure Bloods have all of
these potions catered to them
everything you have to go out and get to
be able to use make the potions
gonna talk to Deke when you're ready
wait what do you hold on
I want to complete this Quest but I
don't want to start a new Quest okay
yeah
that's right we still need to talk to
him
about altering the professor Weasley
said I should ask you about changing the
rooms and Ambiance of course huh what
sort of overall look most appeals to you
uh natural let's do natural and
everything
I like this though I'm Outdoors
yeah Dustin
saves a lot of time too
that little apply all option right there
when you're making the uh
changes to the structure keep this style
I like it
to change it back
you can change it duration
excuse me the room is full of
possibilities you changed it
individually on all of them so how much
spend here
I figured it would take you longer than
an hour honestly if you had well no I
guess half an hour sounds about right
if I mean especially if you have the
full
the full room of requirement
you can see we're getting an expansion
right now
and my life is a lot you didn't know
either Dr Sherman what the room equips
itself to your knees all right maybe I
need to make a video on that guys
maybe we need a video on that
space four of them both inside and
outside the school
thank you Professor I shall keep an eye
out
good I'll leave you to it this is your
space now
who's it wisely
all right
and we're almost to level 16.
I think Pippin has all the potions the
magic knee pads like the ingredients but
they might sell potions too
broadens the mind
how about ignatia getting hit with a
Nerf you guys
you all didn't see this
ignacia wild Smith and the flu flames
she used to talk a lot but apparently
they have toned it down in the latest
update all right first I want to buy
from you today
oh he's got the recipes too
man we do not have a lot of money though
right the adoras is 300
Maximus 300.
focus is 500.
all right Maxima okay we're definitely
buying the maximum one oh wise decision
thank you
invisibility all right and then let's go
ahead and buy the focus as well and then
I still think we'll have enough to buy a
focus potion
the duras potion
and Maxima
thank you lumos maxima
lawyer with a hydrate redeemed thank you
my friend
[Music]
all roads lead to hogsmeade
what you think
I think all of these are downgrades so
we might as well go ahead and
sell all of these it brings us back up
to 8.92. we're so poor now
I hope on this character we have nothing
other oh wait hold on he also he has a
job for us which I don't wanna it's
gonna
enable that Quest I think and make it
active but we can just go back in and
switch it out with the delivery yes I do
capable student such as yourself should
have no trouble making the trip to
Cambridge it's just south of Hogwarts in
a posture check redeemed Wang ordered a
few invisibility potions I used to go
myself
into turning every visit into an
argument hmm constantly complaining
about the quality of my stock but how
can I maintain Excellence which you
order so often give me no time to brew
if you take this rather irritating task
off my hands I'd happily allow you to
claim the delivery fee from Fatima
yeah Cloud Roth once you get your room
of requirement built up there's really
no point to buy the potions as long as
you have the ingredients and the recipe
and everything yeah you can just you can
have so much going in the room of
requirement I'd be happy to help with
the delivery I forgot I'm playing evil I
should have said she sounds annoying
here are the invisibility requested
hopefully she won't just have it trouble
she's a talented questionnaire in her
own right I didn't have it I wouldn't
mind having a look supposed to be
playing evil on this one day
all right it's fine we're just we're
deceiving him
he doesn't know he doesn't know
all right he just gave us four
invisibility potions yeah so see it made
that the active Quest
so I need to go switch it back to the
map chamber
Sebastian
what is up dude
there goes Eddie cleaver
there goes Eddie
he's fleeing Annabelle is not happy with
him
oh I think we can do this one now
because we we do have confringo
nice
all right and we did hit Level 16.
all right fig should be waiting for us
it's night time though I don't know if
we can start it up yet or not I might
have to wait
I will oh there he is he's ready dude
he's ready you're back finally
Minister spavin talks more than he
listens ranted on and on about roads I
always said we listen to a word about
goblins
speaking of which listen professor so
much happened while you were away I
received a flurry of messages from
Professor Black's house self-scrope
scrope sent you messages yes I thought
it was odd too he asked me to meet him
and then told me to take the toast why
would you want to take toast under the
lake that's where I found them so it
changes the dialogue Who on
this Richard jackdaw he was a student
here long ago anyways we had the
Slytherin version of the quest I went
there and right next to jackal's
skeleton
found the missing pages you found the
pages I did and because jackdaw had
followed you yes sir contained when I
found the pages I found the location on
the map believe it or not it's a room
below Hogwarts why am I not surprised
shall we I was hoping you'd say that
oh yes big let's go
we gotta show you
that's right this is his first time
going down here isn't it the room is
called the map chamber by the way
and the portrait of Percival Rackham
awaits us there
Professor Rackham I look forward to
meeting him you know him don't get the
pages from the book
hold on why was it locked he's stole
them and Jack door stole them from him
fingers
Rebellion
okay
some of those you can't
oh wait hold on oh that's one of those
yeah we'll get it later
we will get that later
we're not worried about money right now
anyway
not worried about money at the moment
oh yeah Hufflepuff that was pretty cool
pretty cool where Hufflepuff gets to go
on their classes I wish it had been
longer though gryffindors was probably
the most
like lengthy actual Quest and none of
them are particularly long but
yeah Hufflepuff definitely gets the
coolest location
that's for sure
you guys didn't know the uh the jackdaw
quest you might have talked about this
last time but yeah it's different based
on which house you're in
and that's really probably the most
significant differences in the whole
game
our uh
is really that Quest it's a minor
dialogue stuff too but that's the
biggest part of it
[Music]
I love this visual effect it's pretty
cool
which we saw a glimpse of this in the
trailer before the game came out
remember if you guys remember
[Music]
[Applause]
hugs made
I'm over here the Forbidden Forest I
feel like and of course
in the lead-ups of the game I thought
fig was a lot more in the know than he
actually ends up being I mean he's just
as lost as you are
trying to to figure all this out
[Music]
where they at where they at
here to see this
there's our boy Percival
let's go talking we've placed the book
on the pedestal as you asked and this is
my mentor
Professor fig
how do you do Professor fig
and you my young friend see now why you
needed to return with a book I do that's
right Dustin George didn't last very
long that you have come you did not make
it to me that you possess extraordinary
magical ability the potential and power
of which will unlock should you prove
yourself worthy the location yeah
in time appear on the map trials that
will test you and give you access to
invaluable knowledge trials that you
must complete on your own do you recall
do that memory viewed in my vaulting
Gringotts
yes you and your friend Charles spoke of
the Porky and of Trials you'd created
for one who could see traces of ancient
magic precisely Charles is another of
the keepers a designation we gave
ourselves centuries ago in light of the
knowledge that we have been bound to
keep hidden
until perhaps now so the passage from
your ruins to Gringotts everything in
the vault the Restricted Section finding
this room none of these was a trial they
were none of this was a trial of the
journey are you kidding they were not
trials themselves the fact that you have
come this far however bodes well the
trials were designed to ensure that the
power and knowledge we have kept secret
for so long does not fall into the wrong
hands
they will test your abilities
interesting innate and learn the kids
there are a better way they could have
done that everything you witness as you
complete the trials will inform what you
choose to do with all that we share you
will need patience the trials have much
to teach you
it will take time
I'm afraid we don't have the luxury of
time
we have waited this long Professor fig
surely a few more respectfully sir while
I do not know the secret you keep I do
know that our young friend here has seen
traces
traces of a powerful dark magic being
wielded by Goblin Kind
and we encountered an uncommonly
powerful Goblin wielding such magic as
we prepare to leave your vault at
gringots
we got a problem
indeed you have a good one Peggy thank
you for being Professor fig I do then in
the light of your considerable skill and
all you have already accomplished we
shall begin yes
wasting time in locating the trials they
may be completed only by one with our
ability
thank you for the follow
I know that Tower it's not far yes let's
go you may have seen it yourself
yep it looks familiar
in another life your young friend is my
first play through life I think as your
Mentor the least I can do is go ahead to
make sure it is safe join me as soon as
you can
no way
that's not true Dustin
I am hidden Merlin
Tower as soon as I can until then
hey careful
and do not tell anyone Dustin I was
looking for some anagrams for
uh Isadora morganock
for something like Morgana is basically
in her name
I was seeing if there was anything
clever with that one but I wasn't really
finding I mean there's a lot of things
that will work technically just in terms
of letters but nothing that screamed
like oh my gosh this is what they meant
I've done that come and see me
all right let's see what she needs us to
complete actually let's take a look at
all of our quests because we got we've
got three waiting right now from
professors
all right so oh she just needs us to pop
balloons that's really easy
then garlic wants us to acquire any use
of venomous tentacula acquire and use a
mandrake
so we need to do that one too
uh that one should be pretty easy gobs
of gobstones
don't really need to do that Summoners
Court
Spell combination practice two
I don't remember that at all
let's just go ahead and do this let's
just go ahead and do it
how long did it take you guys before you
realized that you just physically cannot
crash in the game like look like
something like that'll happen before you
actually crash
hold on do we do we glitch no there we
go
I mean you can literally just like go
right into a tree
like when the game first came out I was
like trying to avoid every tree oh my
gosh you know don't hit the limbs and
then I realized oh you can literally
just fly right through the mall it
doesn't hurt anything
can literally just fly through every one
of them
about 3.7 seconds because you
immediately went for the ground
when you got your broom
yeah I'm kind of surprised I mean I
guess they just figured people would be
constantly falling off their broom and
such if they did that
sand bakar's tower wait so the first one
is Sans Tower
I thought it was percival's trial
over here
because bakar I thought was one of the
last ones that you do
all right fig
what do you got for us we are not
run rocks loyalists around a dozen I can
see but could be more can't we operate
past them into the tower we could but
we've no idea what's in the tower more
importantly however I'd like to know why
they're here they've set up camp just
ahead I suggest we investigate a little
before doing anything else let's go
before okay that works
it is his but it's in the other's Tower
this way and I'd suggest wait what do
you mean
it's like wait hold up it is his it's
the cars but then what do you mean by
it's in the others Tower
all right I need to
we still don't even have the fourth
spell diamond unlocked just yet
uh let's go I'm gonna put that actually
we already have that right there so
we'll wait and go stealth as we get
closer
okay it's percivals
but I was on the other spell diamond
whoops
glad this is just a tutorial
well done
I think it says a lot about how fun the
combat is in this game that
the vast vast vast majority of people
playing it
do not want to even do stealth they just
want to do combat
and what's crazy is like stealth I mean
stealth is ridiculously powerful like if
you just went all stealth
the upgrades that you get I mean the
game's just
it would make it so much easier if you
just went stealth on everything
what is a grab horn yeah you don't even
hear me so
look at you wandering around aimlessly
don't even know what you're talking
about dude
oh got both of them let's go Revenue
would you look at this we have a note
orders directly from Round Rock oh
search the tower and surrounding area
look for anything to do with the names
what you find here could be the key to
Goblin Kind finally taking its rightful
place in the world ran Rock
this is something funny about picturing
Rand Rock sitting down and writing out a
letter
writing out a letter and signing is
signing his name at the bottom
wait how did you even know I was here
bro
that makes no sense
no I want incendio
I'm not gonna use wigging world I'm
saving it
many goblins have always been any more
goblins
you loved it at the beginning of the
game Scooby rarely went stealth Dustin
your current characters also I mean I
think it might be fun to try to do a run
like that
going stealth as much as you can
[Music]
but yeah it's just the combat's just so
fun
revelio
and that like normally in games I love
stealth I love going stealth
and trying to just like not let anybody
detect me it's more than me a
coincidence that we encountered Round
Rock's loyalists here but this game's
also not really built for that either I
don't feel like like I don't feel like
like that area right there that's
actually a perfect example
like I was trying to go through stealth
and then there's an automatic cut scene
that triggers and
and the guy finds me anyway
but I love games like uh like Dishonored
I you'll have whole areas where you can
just Rebellion you can completely take
out everyone through stealth
or just completely avoid in some areas
all right what do we have down here
I remember exploring this area the first
time
I can't get too far away from fig
because we're on a quest it'll start
giving me the little
they'll start freaking out
Cobra plays you just completed the game
and made a new file nice yeah this is my
uh this is my second playthrough
we're going with hard mode and
a full Evil dark arts character on this
one so
can't imagine the Copelands know about
the trials
they know that something is significant
about this place though it makes it a
lot easier when you have all the dark
arts and I don't even have all of them
yet but I just I already know Rebellion
I already know it's locked
it's locked Big's like allow me an
unlocking John
very handy no time now but if you don't
learn it soon enough we can work on it
back at the Castle come on fig you
should teach me that right now
instead you're gonna wait for our buddy
Gladwin Moon
to approach
oh you can go back to disillusionment
and lose them again when stuff like that
happens
that's interesting
oh I did not know that was
I thought it was a little uh note or
something I imagine these brooms have
been Enchanted for centuries never seen
an enchantment last this long you have
the dishonor games yeah they're so good
foreign
okay welcome to San bakar's tower all
right
on another lock right there
I actually don't remember ever going
back to see
what's behind there
unless you have to you may have to to
complete the story
hello professor
did you say sambakar's Tower I did
Professor bakar is a keeper here's our
explanation on the time I'm glad to see
that I was correct in presuming that we
would meet again soon after our last
encounter though I surmise based on the
commission he told me to find this did
you do not have an easy time getting to
me we did not Professor did you not we
encountered goblins outside the tower
the Goblins were aware of my fault is
disquieting enough I played the first
horizon connection
then the threat may be greater than I
thought all the more reason for us to
move forward downstairs near the entry a
reservoir of ancient magic like those
you've seen before has been unlocked
commanded to access a doorway
dude as Professor fig cannot join you he
and I will in time see you back at the
map chamber remember what you see
we're going to need to understand how
ranrock's loyalists knew about a tower
that once belonged to a keeper
for the moment however even more
important things to set your mind to a
reservoir of ancient magic I believe yes
sir then yes matters in your
increasingly capable hands that said be
careful yeah I thought fig was just
going to be way more in the know
I mean he is he's he's kind of a mentor
but
he's really just kind of along for the
ride you know near the entry
he is definitely not the one with with
like all the answers if that's what
you're expecting going in
you highly recommend doing a let's play
of uh Horizon oh yeah I have so many
games on my backlog that I want to play
either or live streaming or for posting
Let's Plays of
and those are Horizon is definitely on
my list definitely the sequel but I
probably need I almost wonder if I
should replay the first game
but yeah I'm kind of in there like I'm
trying to decide right now what what is
going to be a let's play versus what is
streamed live and then
still brought over to YouTube but
I feel like
a lot of times the story stuff
is a little bit harder for life for a
live stream because
I'm so immersed in the story that I feel
like I ignore chat too much
and see this one I've already played the
story so I'm not I'm not having to focus
on it as much as I would if this is my
first playthrough
revelia
what do you guys think is that
that a phoenix on all of these
or is it like a Thunderbird
is there's a couple of crests throughout
this game that you find when you're
going through the older areas
oh here we go the first trial
it is time
back to back on Horizon yeah that'd
probably be a good one to do that for
yeah the DLC is supposed to be coming
out next month they've like barely said
anything on the Restricted Section
which I mean you know it's it's gonna be
solid but I'm wondering like is it
actually ready or is it about to get
a surprise delay what is going on
maybe they just don't want to show a lot
all right I can't remember if there's
any
Secret in this area leading up to
now you can destroy all of those but
it's like
what's the point
hello
all right so we can go down this way
investigate
old Gryffindor Crest well I think hasn't
Gryffindor always been a lion though
hello there
house emblem scarf
this mechanic I I don't feel like they
use this mechanic enough with these
little portals
but then again I don't know maybe
there's something to be said for not
overusing mechanics and keeping things
fresh
but every time that I had that mechanic
I thought it was so
they were very creative with it
you know what
definitely going to keep those equipped
but I don't love the
look hold on wrong one
so let's go and change you to the dark
arts gloves
lavender patch scarf unupgraded
or I should say not an upgrade to what
we currently have
no
okay I think we were good anyway
he's a never welcome sight
at least I know what to expect actually
I mean I think they are welcome sight I
love fighting these things
some of my favorite enemy in the game to
fight these guys right here
well I was trying to throw it at you
boom Oh my gosh that is does such good
damage on him
and Expelliarmus has a pretty quick
cooldown
all right we just took him out of the
battle
oh my gosh we took the weapon from him
used it on his buddy
that is awesome I feel like it makes
those guys so much easier once you have
that ability
all right so we have kind of a little
branching plan for me path right here
I can't use my Dash
why can I not Dash
Violet lock scarf not an upgrade either
foreign
not an upgrade oh yeah princess somebody
just posted it in the chat so it's has a
little bit of a cool down timer so
that's probably why it
didn't pop up again just yet
Rebellion
all right let's look at the other side
here
and I think we just looks familiar
Pacquiao on this
revelio
I'm always paranoid there's like
something down below that you can unlock
all right wait a second
how do we get
how do we get over there
where is
and I think I saw a
oh yeah where is that chest at hold on
foreign
yes it was
I know I've gotten this on my first
playthrough
a zodiac with a hydrate
oh yeah nobody no no banned words have
been redeemed tonight
no banned words at the moment
the pig we might have to do this we
might have to investigate before the
other part will open up
there we go
I don't think this is ever explained
either is it like where where is it
exactly I am passing into when I do this
what sort of world
is this like a dark world or is this
some some sort of ancient Magic
and there it is
there's the chest
could not reach previously
and hey look at that Periwinkle hat
not only is it a Periwinkle hat it's an
upgraded
which at this point on a second
playthrough I'll take it
do not grab that
every night there's a band word the
price gets cheaper
I feel like it should be the other way
Cloud Roth
every night there's a ban word the price
should increase
that's what I feel
Rebellion all right make sure there's
nothing on the ground here that we're
missing
I feel like I'm getting a little bit too
far away from the mic
all right see now we're in kind of like
a different
we're in the red realm right now
so it feels like we're backtracking but
I actually think
hold on are we heading the right way
okay well it definitely worked for
getting it no no no now we gotta go back
over here that's right
nope nope nope I want you to yep you
already messed up now
you've already messed up now
this is racquet tour you have enough I
think everybody I think a lot of people
have enough they just can't figure out
what word they want to use
which word should we ban
oh my goodness
yeah you really take those guys down
quick
and you can hit them with the expelli
armas
ancient magic throw let's roll in do an
incendio and he's almost done
oh expelliarma's finished him off
so much pressure I'm not sure what words
all right so we're all cleared out there
here
I think we can make that jump right
oh wait what in the world
I presume I'm looking for traces of
ancient Magic
but where
oh I remember it's like hold on how do
we get this
okay wait I think we have to go over to
the other side
hogsmeeter Hogwarts I think somebody did
everybody did hog one time and I was
like
because they were
okay
one in the world
okay that was insane
that's right Paula yes it was you used
hog and then they tried to say that that
meant I couldn't say Hogwarts or Hogs me
it's like come on that's a different
word
it is a different word
has hog and both of them have hog inside
Rebellion
all right should we go that way nope
oh hold on we can't get access to that
one yet
okay let's go through here
we're supposed to go down here
oh yes yes yes okay
question is which way do we need to pass
through do we need to go
okay that one's kind of clear and then
this one is blue seems like old to
explore this up go to the blue realm
okay we're in the blue Realm
let's see where the blue realm takes us
all right I don't think that's supposed
to go back that way
actually no no no no no hold on
okay yeah we want to bring it over this
way
bring it over this way
and now we go over here
accio can reach I didn't know if it was
hydrate and then spam with hydrates oh
my goodness
then I just can't say what you guys are
redeeming huh
I just could not say what is being
redeemed
okay I don't remember
I don't remember what to do next on this
part
I need to see how the room changes when
I move in and out of the archway
oh
yeah yeah we already saw how the room
changes
all right so we're in the blue realm
right now
okay so now this is the red Realm
wait wait wait that should work now
right
I can use that one to pull myself closer
give me your word
back here
yes because now we have this platform
right here
that
there we go
welcome in to the new follow let's see
Ali
asia96. thank you so much for the follow
welcome in I'll never get used to these
flaws
oh here we go
wait did insidio just completely miss
him right there
where did you come from sir
no
I'm not gonna I'm trying not to heal
wait wait hold on we do have a buddy
Chinese chomping cabbage go
foreign
I don't know why I'm putting this
artificial Challenge on myself
don't ask me why but I enjoy doing it
oh still too far away for incendio darn
it why did I use that on him
no we're still alive
how are we still alive
we totally should have died from that
should we not
ice
wait should we weren't we at zero
and then we took that hit
and then we have our IRL word band
ladies and gentlemen if you're watching
this
in the VOD in the let's play over on
YouTube later we do this
Channel Point Redemption where people
can redeem their Channel points that
they earn by watching live in the Stream
to ban a word that I can't say for the
next 15 minutes
and it looks like we have a word
hold on hold on wait it can't be wait
I thought we said oh I think I changed
the rule to say like proper nouns
or just regular
or just regular nouns
but you know what I'm in a generous mood
we'll do it we'll do it I'm in a
generous mood okay wait
wait
w-a-i-t all right so for the next 15
minutes ladies and gentlemen starting
now
well no no not now hold on
okay so right now this is the last time
I can say the word
oh wait
the timer has begun
yeah at least at least it's not the
we had that one once before we did we
had that one once before
pandemonium ladies and gentlemen
absolute pandemonium
now I don't even know
almost said it almost said it right
there
dude maybe I say that word a lot
and Chrissy's been very observant
trying to figure out okay what word does
he say a lot
that we can ban
it's when I'm in an area and I'm kind of
thinking for a second about where we
should go next so that I'm usually like
the word
hold on hold on needs to be what I say
instead
what happens if you say the word I don't
know we need to come up with
something for that
I thought about doing a donation every
time
like I have to do a random giveaway
of like
I don't know maybe we would have to
start it small at five dollars or
something but
every time I say it
but yeah right now there's no punishment
oh my gosh I'm so afraid
foreign
said
I say that word a lot
I did not think this one was going to be
that hard but here we are
okay
let's see where we need to go next
this is where
it's pointing
revelio
over here maybe
all right investigate
but weren't as bad nice try Evo nice try
that was a good effort that was a very
good effort
why do I have to investigate that again
okay I think it's good now
that was so close
this one actually tripped me up a little
bit on my first playthrough
because
we need to get over there
I don't think this is right but
oh my gosh I I do say that word a lot
holy cow
I've wanted to say it so many times
already
no freaking way
okay
do we have to go
I usually make things way harder than
they need to be so maybe I just go here
pull you through
you don't want to go through the portal
come on
now see Dustin if I said that
I would argue I'm in the clear it is a
different word
if I talked about how heavy or light I
am as a person
okay why is it
just go ahead and go over here
because I know I want to get that chest
anyway
drop down here
golden trimmed School robe
of course it's not an upgrade
okay
that right there
did that change things up
I don't think so I don't think it
changed anything
so what needs to happen we have to reach
this point over here
only one that trips you up
oh this this little puzzle area gotcha
and obviously I've already solved it
once
we don't have to pulso
I think I remember I think I remember
we almost have it
if if I'm correct
stop there
yes
questions
there we go
got it
nice nice nice Mr Cupcake 17 with the
follow
thank you so much Mr Cupcake appreciate
that
take a few wig and weld Potions there
and we proceed
onward onward we go
Into the Depths
more Wigan welds you know what that
means
boss fight time
I love this fight right here
I got lucky right there
had the invincibility
oh that was quick
see right there you get a little bit of
invincibility
I think we got a heel here
incentive
ouch
back off dude
here we go
where did you come from good sir
where did you come from
okay fine
I have to quit being stubborn with the
Wigan welds they did give us a lot of
Wigan welds right before that fight so
I think we're fine
we have confringo right there I need to
be using that too
oh yeah that was really nice
so confringo after
dude they take away half my health
and then confringo no no
he almost knocked me off completely
nice okay you're gone
uh switch switch
there we go nicely done not too bad not
too bad
so yeah
this guy is so fun
I love this fight
as I'm trying to change my my spell to
the correct one
all right
all right do it do it do it
[Music]
I was thinking he has the curse effect
no I forgot about that part
we are down a lot of Wigan welds
[Music]
okay that's good ancient Magic
this is one of my favorite fights in the
game actually
okay there we go get away get away get
away
and what's great is it really serves as
a preview
to the final boss
if you think about the mechanic used in
the final boss area
there we go get that Stupify in there
no we gotta get away we gotta get away
just in time
first time I got to this fight I was
freaking out with excitement
I bet we have to do one more
there it is
there it is let's go
that guy's so cool
I think that is a really fun fight
what a relief
I forgot it was this early
I did not remember it being the very
first
trial
and we used
we have two Wicked welda potions left
two wiggin welds
have that over there
get this right here
unidentified outfit item
let's activate the pensive Percival
rackham's memories
thank goodness cutscene
I can be quiet
I don't have to talk I can let the
cutscene play
so I don't have to worry about the band
word
no it doesn't have words though and when
it doesn't have words I feel like I need
to be talking still
actually this one may not have words at
all
this specific cut scene here
your ability to transfigure the world
around you is
what is it
my father isn't getting better
I don't think he'll ever recover from
the death of my brother
it is agonizing to see those we love
suffer
the trout was years ago but the pain of
losing him is as deep for him now as if
it happened only yesterday
he doesn't need pretty pillars he needs
peace
what if I could help him professor you
know so much for your father already
it's not enough
skin
it is tempting I know to use this magic
that you're mastering to transfigure
more than the physical world
human emotion is a potent Force unto
itself
even the most well-meaning and competent
witch cannot possibly know the
consequences
watch as my father's pain destroys him
we're done we made it
15-minute band word is complete it's a
way to get
she didn't like that dude
she was not happy every year a student
sees something sillier than I could ever
imagine in their tea leaves
oh Miss Morgan welcome back to Hogwarts
professor
going to take some getting used
I was so pleased to hear that you'd
accepted the position of defense against
the dark arts Professor so how big of a
Time skip do you think there was right
there tell us about your travels
I was actually hoping that you and the
others might join me at my home this
evening
there's much I'd like to share with you
that would be delightful we shall let
the others know very well I shall see
you then
so I guess she just went away after
graduating and never told them that or
they never found out she kept pursuing
all of that easily 15 years yeah I mean
I was thinking another memory
now to find a way out of there
okay well if nothing else Christy you
definitely showed me how much I say wait
maybe that was like a subtle not so
subtle
Metro you gotta stop saying that
work come on
so yeah I'm gonna be working on that but
I totally do like when I'm exploring
areas
crystallized Stone I could just
as I was going through there were so
many times I want to be like wait wait
what is this
wait you guys oh my goodness
wait what did you see that
so many times
okay why is this
lighting up can we repair all that
I don't think we can but then
oh wait wait
wait
there it is for a second it looked like
it was going to work
that is so weird
it looks like we should be able to
repair and put it back there but
maybe I destroyed it when I walked in
here and didn't even remember doing it
all right back into the map chamber we
go
all right after this little cut scene
with fig
I'm gonna make sure I save the last hour
on my PlayStation so I have that footage
in case we need it for any future videos
I'm a student at Hogwarts sir and this
is Professor Fick professor Charles Rook
ordered your service
At Your Service Charles I have Professor
Brookwood
I've seen you before you in the pensive
in Gringos with Professor raccoon indeed
so you found the port key to access
Professor rackham's Vault and you
deciphered the map within the locket you
found floating above that pensive I did
I found something that I can't identify
floating above the last pensive ah yes
you will find a similar artifact in each
trial you must take care to keep them
safe you'll need them to complete the
journey we have set forth for you once
you have them all we will tell you what
to do with them very well
are you able to tell me anything about
the next trial
before you proceed I would like to speak
with Charles regarding the Urgent
situation involving the goblins
goblins
the student has seen traces of a
powerful dark magic being wielded by
Goblin Kind
they and their Mentor Professor fig yes
it's like the release you know it's been
holding all the weights in they also
encountered a powerful Goblin in my
vault at Gringotts
hmm
I'm afraid it would be wise to Halt the
trials until we know more
we shall defer to you in this matter of
course
why are we taking orders from portraits
by the way Professor the name Rookwood
it's not actually them you know you guys
ever think about that
but we can't be sure of its significance
if any why are we letting the portraits
run this what you saw in the pensive
before the witch from the last pensive
Isadora became a Hogwarts professor she
argued with Professor Rackham about
using magic to remove pain hmm hopefully
the next pensive provides more context
for now we should learn what round rock
knows I will be honest I've no idea
where to start actually I might know of
someone I saw sirona at the three
broomsticks speaking to a goblin once
time for us to meet our buddy see what
you can find out
my studies
yes sir
uh before you go
before you go
it's like it Christy it gets back to
that whole
Wizarding World magical question again
though I remember
was it on Pottermore or somewhere JK
Rowling eventually answered because
people kept asking like okay the the
Headmaster portraits right
like it's not actually them
it's not actually the professor
and it's not it's not even like
necessarily
I can't remember how she described it I
need to look this up though
Professor have you encountered Swift and
echo or something in the world
aside from those along power path not
that I recall
what are they evidence of the Keeper's
efforts to manipulate the power of
ancient magic during our time if have a
go in Marielle thanks for being here
you should be able to use them to inform
and enhance your own magic thank you sir
I will look out for them
we will look out for them
snapdragonet thank you for the follow
welcome in also Mr Cupcake with a follow
as well
a little bit ago appreciate you all
being here
and I think we just had a season change
right there
believe we just had a season change
all right actually you know what I think
I'm gonna call it I think I'm gonna call
it a night it is almost
11 40. it's midnight here so
I'm going to call it a night so thank
you guys so much for being here